one of my favorite thinkers one of the
people who I imagined myself reading and
studying and probably writing about and
talking about the rest of my life is
Aristotle and in a way I came to
Aristotle a bit late in my career if you
understand your career in terms of your
your philosophical formation I've been
working on Aristotle more or less
non-stop than teaching Aristotle more or
less non-stop since my my graduate
school days but I didn't get into him
until I was a graduate student I'll talk
about that in a moment
you can't say that I went through an
Aristotelian phase because I never got
captivated with Aristotle the way I did
with say niche or Sartre or Hegel and
where I was you know trying to see
everything through the lens of them but
the Aristotle grew on me more and more
and although I would not call myself an
Aristotelian in the sense of you know
subscribing to everything that being
that he teaches in his in his ethics and
it was in his metaphysics broadly
understood I would say that I am very
influenced by Aristotle and in many
respects there's some things that I
think he got he got definitively right
and some insights that he had that
unless you have those insights I'm gonna
turn the Aristotle's it to get those
because I think that they're so
important oh I'll talk about those in a
few minutes as well so how did I get
into Aristotle like I said it didn't
happen until I was in grad school and it
didn't happen right away in grad school
either when I was an undergraduate we
had to read Aristotle and we had that
anthology I think by Khan classics of
Western philosophy and it had the nickel
McCain
things in it and think of you portions
the politics and some of the logical
works including the categories and I was
assigned the categories that was the
first book of aristotle i ever
encountered and i read through it i was
like what the hell is this why am I
reading this sort of stuff because you
know what seemed right in it seemed just
very commonsensical and then there was
all this stuff that just didn't make
sense about being in a subject or being
predicated of a subject and my
instructors really didn't do much of a
job in explaining it I think in part
because they were not very interested in
Aristotle themselves they were very into
existentialism and more contemporary
stuff and I don't think they really
liked Aristotle so when I got to
graduate school of course ahead Easter
reading Aristotle for my master's exams
and that was only one one exam but it
was pretty it was pretty tough via D
answer one question on a pool of three
on ancient philosophy one on a pool of
three on medieval one out of three on
modern and then one on nineteenth
century and so of course I had to prep
by studying some Aristotle I ended up
answering a Plato question and
interestingly enough not an heiress
level question and I even that I was not
particularly interested in Aristotle but
I had a friend who was very interested
in him and this friend of mine
was learning Greek and he said you know
when you can read Aristotle in Greek
it's going to make all the difference in
the world
yeah I've talked about this a little bit
in the the video that I have on
languages I did in fact learn classical
Greek and I learned it in part so I
could read people like Plato
but then Aristotle was somebody who I
started reading in part to work on my
Greek and in part
because I got I found more and more
enjoyment and and benefit in doing so he
and so they're really a bunch of things
converging about halfway through my
graduate school career and so I learned
Greek one of the things that you have to
do when you're learning a language after
you've learned the grammar and you've
done some composition stuff is actually
start reading authors and texts in the
language and that means you have to
learn the lexicon you have to learn the
way they put things together and so
generally you'll do readings classes and
so I did you know a semester reading
class for example on Plato's symposium
with one guy I did a one on Herodotus as
history with another person well I
decided I wanted to work on Aristotle
some so I thought well I'll read the
nick of McCain ethics and I'll do it in
Greek so that's what we did one semester
I worked with this guy Johnson I think
Doug Johnson was maybe his name and he
liked Aristotle and so we we read the
Nicomachean ethics in Greek and each
week we'd meet and go over it and he was
not a philosopher by training he was a
classicist so he you know he said well
I'm gonna let you handle you know
figuring out whether this is
philosophically adequate or enough and
another thing that we did that was very
interesting is we we also looked at
translations but we look not only at
English translations but also at French
translations and a few you know every
once in a while German translations just
to see how they would how they would
render certain passages and what was
really fascinating to find out was that
at least the French translations that I
had they were very periphrastic compared
to the English translations which tended
to be a bit more more sticking to the
the literal text so there was that and
then I was I began reading Aristotle
also for the preliminary examination
the school that I went to back then we
had four preliminary examinations that
you had to take before you got to start
writing your dissertation and each one
of these was the equivalent of the
master's exam that you take in so you
had to answer four questions out of a
pool of questions and generally you
would take a lot of time to prepare
because the reading lists were very
extensive and they included a lot of
Aristotle because there was you know
metaphysics and philosophy of religion
so the metaphysics part you know a lot
of Aristotle than that epistemology and
philosophy of science so all of
Aristotle's logical works were in there
and the D anima of course and then when
we recall value fields which which
included politics aesthetics and ethics
well guess what Aristotle had something
to say about all of those and actually
wrote works on all of them so I didn't
read the entire Rishta Tilian corpus but
I read a good portion of it or reread it
in a lot of respects and I was reading
very attentively because I had to be
able to reproduce this in innocence sort
of some synthetic comprehensive form on
the examination making sense out of
things that was a really good practice I
I'm all for making people take
examinations like that and do the
studying for it because I found it
really helpful
I gave me this reservoir of knowledge
that I could draw upon later later and
it also introduced me to by forcing me
to read and reread and study Aristotle
it led me down the path by which I could
actually see what he was driving at I'm
a little dense and sometimes it takes me
you know more than one time or ten times
to figure out what's going on in a text
and depth that process of having to
focus and focus and focus eventually
sort of vistas opened up for me and I
said oh that's what this is about
another thing that happened to was I was
taking courses outside of the philosophy
department Nacho's to the classics but
also with the English
Cartman I was taking classes on rhetoric
and I was taking classes over in speech
communications having to do a semiotic
s-- as it turns out Aristotle's thought
on language fits into both of these and
we in fact spent a good portion of time
studying Aristotle's rhetoric also you
know Plato's Phaedrus and gorgeous and
if you know someone Cicero's works in
order to make sense out of how we ought
to use language and so unlike a lot of
philosophers I actually have a great
respect for the rhetoric and also for
the poetics which is an unfinished work
but I think is very important and that
leads me to the the the next thing one
of the things that happened for me was
when I was able to read Aristotle in the
Greek I started to see that there were
connections in his work at the lexical
level in terms of the terminology and
the concepts that he was using that were
you might say overlooked or broken in
the acts of translation and why is this
well you know you'll have a bunch of
different translators of the Nicomachean
ethics over here and they try to frame
things as best they can and in English
to make sense of it for a contemporary
audience and then somebody else is
translating the politics over here and
the same word the same term that's being
used which might not be used in the same
way by the way to Aristotle would
sometimes use this the same word but in
multiple senses but in any case the same
term may get translated in a very
different way and you don't see the
connection between these two discussions
sometimes even within the same work you
don't see the connections going on there
that Aristotle is actually discussing
the same sort of thing unless you can
read the Greek or you have a you know
great translation or
concordance or something like that well
anyway I was reading Aristotle in the
Greek you know certainly the the two
ethics and the politics the rhetoric and
then dabbling when the poetics and the
topics and the de anima and I started
seeing all these different important
connections between things between
different discussions and it makes good
sense because it's the same guy writing
all this stuff and Aristotle was a very
comprehensive systematic kind of thinker
so it does stand to reason that he there
would actually be connections between
the discussions in these different texts
but a lot of people don't don't see them
and don't draw on them so their
understanding of Aristotle tends to be a
bit more truncated and not to
incorporate all this other stuff that
would give you a richer picture so I was
seeing that richer picture and that by
itself drew me in and and made this into
a mode of thought and a body of work
that I wanted to keep working on I'm
working out of working out because it
opened up more and more interesting
topics and questions more than I can
probably explore in my entire lifetime
so that's how I got into Aristotle and
then I started writing papers on
Aristotle and some of them were
presented at conferences a few of them
have been published here and there I
think it published about four or five
things on Aristotle so far and
eventually I decided I wanted to start
writing a book on Aristotle in his
discussions of anger bringing all these
these threads that I see in about well
nine or ten different texts all of them
together and and talking about it as a
systematic theory as best as one can and
then comparing it to other people's
discussions and theories and treatments
of
I'm also very interested in Aristotle's
conception of shared common goods and
political life and culture and moral
perception and so I do some writing on
those sorts of things I'm very
interested in Aristotle's metaphysical
scheme as well although I don't
necessarily buy into to all of it the
way that you know somebody who calls
himself Sania Aristotelian might do but
I think that he came up with some some
really useful ways to understand a lot
of key things and I think that if he had
a few more tools in his belt if he'd
come on the scene a bit later
his works might have been yet even more
powerful than incorporating a lot of
things so Aristotle is is an important
thinker and there's there's something
you know use a respectable thinker to
focus on anyway if you're in philosophy
and somebody says well what kind of
stuff do you do you it's always a safe
bet to say I'm an Aristotle scholar
because everybody knows who he is and
even if they don't like Aristotle at
least he knows part of that part of the
Canon and you're doing some sort of
reputable business that's different than
saying something like well I'm a Lacan
scholar which may not go over too well
in many circles or I'm interested in
Maurice blown down on that everyone says
Maurice who or you know Saint Anselm
scholar everyone thinks that you work on
the ontological argument all the time
why is Aristotle such a such an
important figure well you know we have
this kind of conception now of the
history of philosophy as all these these
periods and all these thinkers and and
there's sort of like canonical figures
like you know Socrates Plato Aristotle
moving forward you know Epictetus seneca
at the Kuras of course a little bit
earlier
sexist empirica cicero you know move
forward all the way to the to the
present and then it gets a little bit
you know more confused what who counts
as a canonical figure you know dick and
stein definitely but you know what about
Carnap you know or who counts and
continental philosophy definitely
Heidegger but what about Baudrillard you
know those are those are interesting
questions but let's put that up so
Aristotle is is now you know sort of an
established figure but there were a lot
of times where he was not studied and
I'm not just talking about you know
during the early Middle Ages when he'd
been lost he wasn't completely lost by
the way to the medievals did know about
him in part through glosses that were
available they lost a lot of his tax and
and later on recovered them through
through the Islamic world that through
these translations that are made
available but it's not as if he was
completely off the scene but he has been
in and out of vogue this is one of the
really interesting things about
Aristotle and Aristotelian philosophy in
some centuries Aristotelian ism was a
dirty word and it might actually be a
good word and a dirty word at the same
time like you know during the 13th
century reception of Aristotle in the in
the universities there are some people
who are like yeah this is the this is
this is the best stuff it wipes away
everything other people people were like
that's the devil you know and then there
were all sorts of things in between
including Thomas Aquinas who had this
very measured approach to to Aristotle
trying to bring in in line with with a
Augustinian theological tradition as
well and incorporating lots of other
sources included John Demasi and Ansel
and all these other all these other
great thinkers
if you move forward a little bit
Aristotle sometimes you know like in the
early medieval or the early modern
period there were these people that were
teaching Aristotle as if Aristotle is
they were almost like fundamentalists of
Aristotle Aristotle said it it must be
it must be the case and that I think
there was much more often just how it
was taught and not that they actually
necessarily thought that but that but
you know that was there was the sort of
rote learning at the time and Descartes
is reacting against that although the
card is actually enlarged in many ways
indebted to scholasticism as Etienne gel
sona's has shown it in his doctoral
dissertation later on you know because
of the eclipses of the moribund
scholasticism that Aristotle got
identified with there's a real lack of
interest in Aristotle for the most part
running throughout modern philosophy and
although they incorporated a lot of a
lot of his ideas you know a lot of his
key terms and concepts they were
approaching them in different ways
there is one one one you know thing that
needs to be said is that there was this
entire tradition not so much in the the
you know German English French areas but
in in other countries particularly in
Italy of focusing on Aristotle's topics
and poetics and rhetoric and seeing
those as essential to to philosophy Vico
would be a great example of this and
then you know you move forward in time
and people start to recover an
appreciation for Aristotle and by the
20th century you know some of the big
heavy hitters are saying yeah Aristotle
he was a great metaphysician he's made
solid contributions of ethics we may not
actually accept his his method but you
know it is there was something going on
there it wasn't just you know a bunch of
dummies the way that the early modern is
often portrayed Aristotle and so I mean
what's really interesting is that there
are periods where Aristotle is totally
involved here and then there are periods
where it's
you don't hear about him at all I'm
gonna read Hume for example and who do
you see Hume talking about the Stoics
the Epicureans Plato Cicero hardly
anything about Aristotle because I mean
who would study that sort of thing
anything talks about a little bit but
not not too much
my interest in Aristotle tends to be a
bit more exclusive than you know the
entire corpus I have to admit I'm not
particularly interested in texts like
the physics or the parts of the animals
for their own sake I'm much more in and
I'm not that interested in the logical
works per se you know like the analytics
for their own sake I am I'm primarily
interested I would say in his human
center trying to make sense out of our
common life our moral life together the
moral distinctions that we make are
evaluations how we develop that sort of
stuff so I'm very interested in the two
ethics the politics the rhetoric I see
all of those is sort of forming a
cohesive whole together connected with
them of course would be the topics the
poetics the de anima and parts of a few
other works as well the constitution of
athens which is really more out more of
a history but tells us something about
you know how these things play
themselves out some of the problems they
actually fit in with that
there are some of these books called the
problems i am also very interested in
his metaphysical point of view and and
that has to do in part with my interest
in the human person but also in his
notion of being as such the actuality
potentiality all these Aristotelian
principles privation you know
what actually constitutes privation I
think he gave us a very useful
vocabulary and set of tools he doesn't
necessarily have the final answer on
everything but he set the agenda for a
lot of research to take place and he
provided us with some very useful at
least you know problems sometimes points
of view sometimes approaches to things
he's an interesting guy in part two I
would say because he is a he is a
systematic thinker but he never works
things out fully systematically he
always leaves all these gaps where we
have to kind of fill things in and where
we have to you know draw connections
between the different texts and where we
have to say well what would eros how
would a Aristotle treat this sort of
thing and and Peart that's because of
his method and his commitments he
thought that you couldn't determine
everything with you know complete
consistency across the board that you
had to develop what he called Furness
it's the ability to actually figure out
how to apply things in particular
situations and his philosophy is
supposed to aid you in in developing
these sorts of things so there you know
there is a good reason for that I think
it's also in large part Aristotle was a
dialectical thinker so he's engaging
with the best thought and explanations
and ideas of his own time and a lot has
happened since then that Aristotle
probably could make sense out of and you
can try to think Adam an Aristotelian
perspective but but he didn't think that
out because you know he's early on in
the history of philosophy I think that
one of the things this is one of the
things that really attracts me to
Aristotle is that his works sort of
begged for incorporation with other
modes of thought there are people who
want to be Aristotelian in the sense
that like you know Aristotle had all the
answers
and we just go to him and reconstitute
things and if he doesn't have something
to say about it himself we we use his
texts to try to come up with a pure
Aristotelian the answer and I've never
found that that very interesting it's
kind of a you know again use a term in a
pejorative sense that it doesn't
necessarily have to have a very
scholastic exercise to do that sort of
thing
I'm interested in Aristotle in part
because I see his way of approaching
things as compatible with although
sometimes in tension with and requiring
you know thinking out quite a bit with
other things that I'm interested in like
phenomenology psychoanalysis Christian
theology and Christian philosophy our
experience of moral life and failure and
evil and and you know breakdowns and all
that sort of stuff
Aristotle gives me and I think he gives
a lot of other people the framework not
necessarily to solve everything to the
but to make sense and to figure out
where to go and and what what resources
to bring to bear on the problems that
were faced with and so I see a lot of
compatibility that I think a lot of
other people don't see
between Aristotle's texts and ideas and
is his fundamental point of view and
these other very interesting and
valuable movements in in philosophy
theology social thought history all
those sorts of things so I would say
Aristotle greatly enriches my own life
of the mind and I know that he does with
other people too because I see other
people who are as excited about
Aristotle as as I am so I'm gonna close
actually by pointing out two things that
I think would be kind of useful for if
you're interested in Aristotle get your
hands on and one is this you know
massive its home the basic works of
Aristotle McCann is the editor of it and
its translations by different people and
it's got pretty much everything that
you're going to want to read through
with the Aristotle it also has the the
lines which is nice if you might
actually want to reference it or
somebody else's referencing and they say
yeah it's a 101 oh-58 b15 okay you can
actually figure out what they're what
they're talking about so this is nice
it's got all the the main works in
translation in one handy volume can't
can't ever beat that unless you of
course go to the Greek this is a Loeb
classic series edition that has the
second half of the metaphysics the
economics and the perhaps pseudo
Aristotelian work Magna moralia I tend
to think of it as being sued
Aristotelian but I'm not a I'm not a
textual scholar that way I do have a
colleague who believes and I want to see
his argument through this that it is in
fact a genuine work of Aristotle and
these are nice in part because you get
the English you get the English on one
side and the Greek texts on the other
side so I I still use these today in
part because sometimes I'll be reading
the Greek and its obscure and I'll say
well what's going on I'll go to the
English translation the translation may
be helpful he actually may actually lead
me sometimes let's say why don't he
translate it that way but in any case
it's kind of nice to yeah that's it's a
good size and these are these are great
books to have I wish I had a lot more of
these as a matter of fact someday
someday my goal is to have like an
entire you know bookshelf just a globe
class of conditions of the different
authors who I work
and all the Loeb additions that I him I
would say that a good on the Greek shelf
a good half of them are actually
Aristotle believe it or not the second
lawyer with the second largest
representation Lucian of Samus toast a
satirical author who I just happen to
like reading but then there's Epictetus
and Hesiod and people like that but the
bulk of it is Aristotle so this gives
you an idea about somebody who's very
important to me and I think is going to
be important for the rest of my life and
career and somebody who I think is
always worth spending the time to read
and study
I love teaching him I've seen students
eyes open up and the light bulb go on
not I haven't seen the light bulb inside
their head but you understand what I'm
saying
I've seen them make so many useful
connections and reading works of
Aristotle maybe more than with any other
philosopher but I do teach a lot of
Aristotle's so I think that's part of it